[Music]
in no shame news no shame in the game
but if where did this come from [ __ ] no
it's stroking a little penis success
okay so no any like that's gonna make
the penis grow bigger when you get more
shameful if the act of filings are like
shaving something shaming it means a lot
of things that we do that we don't know
I've never done this [ __ ] shame shame
shame submitted by Chrissy from Down
Under
down on da hi Christine I'd like the
Aussie places we woman was filmed giving
a lap dance nice to a stranger on a
flight to Ibiza
what because there's a like Ibiza yeah
that makes sense
yeah you're supposed to act like a dirty
scoundrel I do have a visa Ibiza this
video you give somebody a lap dance I
just on a plane on a plane they're
probably gonna go some space maybe she
sat down trying to come back from the
bathroom and she fell in his lap and
they were like oh sorry oh ah oh that's
probably what it was is good what's the
funny scenario - whales my job anyway
why I roll them back kind of a good good
he likes his job so when I first saw his
videos 25th of incentive to me late at
night and I was opening out like what
the [ __ ] is it super sexual it looks
like they're straight up
wow that was like oh my god we got
talking about on jegging is so cute it
oh yeah show what's the picture it looks
like her skirt oh [ __ ] look at that
asian dude topically well you know that
was life we own I spawn all baby
ha ha ha ha ha somebody be called it and
get the we do here we go
Jack
[Music]
I have a tattoo on his whole forearm he
doesn't look like a tattoo man you're
worried about the asian dude when this
girls over here is like grinding up I
know she wasn't dance to anything she
was crying in on us she was kissing
they're kissing who's riding at this she
was like all up on his neck I couldn't
see that like us riding and he was
grabbing her ass yeah she had a poor
ghana mater idaho you bet you that uh
looking at i didn't see any of it every
play Frank you see the video
so there is not much happening she's not
doing anything right now at all yeah
just on his lap she's not doing any
she's straddling him now this one BAM
she's not even moving yes huh look
closely look at 25 I mean yeah that
grinding maybe I'm not I mean sometimes
can you show them on this chair real
quick
for the viewers and usually she just
froze like this no Chester gone like
gyrating maybe she does have a bootie
stuck on top oh that's right so it turns
out that this one because they look like
just go back in I know what you're doing
you know what's interesting you don't
want to know deeply okay she was number
loved something I think I think is
waiting for you okay so it looked like
she had taken off her her bottoms right
but in reality she was ring shortened oh
this flight was heading to a visa from
Australia from Manchester oh I didn't
guess it right they were heading over
there and so apparently what the story
is is that this woman my name's Tracy 39
years old she had gotten really drunk
I knew it with a group of friends and
then the dude Shawn 31 years old he was
also drunk
but he's really really shady so he was
on his way to a visa for a bachelor
party
and he left behind his pregnant fiancee
and then he's over here like grinding up
on his later this lady's right on this
video leaked Oh
but the but it's a bachelor party so
what happened is during the bachelor
party
hey at the bachelor party last you tell
so he was it's been reported that he was
around I like calling out if anyone had
a jelly which is aka condom so he's over
here asking the people in the airplane
if they had a condom so he was very
clearly trying to cheat on his fiancee
good but what happens at the bachelor
party stays in the past but that wasn't
the bachelor party and how did he ditch
his he left the prego fiance at the
airport
no like at home uh Marty technically
started yep right what as far as the
moment you leave it that way you believe
in yeah that's a bachelor party rule you
just left there oh then he can't he
can't offer it's okay if we're going
based off of bachelor that rule then
yeah from what I seen for white people
do on TV
you know that's the Vegas slogan right
it's not the bachelors level is the bash
that goes for all bachelor party no I
thought that's what I assumed from Y P
what's the point of bachelor parties
oh the white people bachelor price yeah
I don't know so what's what's the point
of us apart is it if it's not to go
shooting I saw this in the movies and
the movies always portray people in the
light right don't like you like the
right light so this is Tracy she's a
mother of three she's a cafe owner she's
also a grinder
she's a grinder she owns a cafe forgiven
love love dances yeah and she's dressed
yeah I should say the shoes
mortified that this video was out cuz no
you're not
how come she was blonde before well and
this is an old picture I guess but she's
blonde in them you know what is so
interesting this is what I always say
people put titles on human beings to
kind of categorize what you think
someone should be like for example you
hear mother of three that doesn't mean
that prior to her having those chairs
she does suck like 60 dijkstra what do
you think those three babies came from
that's what I'm sucking lap dancing and
stroking inside another three [ __ ]
yeah but that's what like when people
see like old people they're like an
acute oh god don't
Bobby murder tell the people you don't
know yep yeah when you see those World
War two vets in documentaries and
talking about their stuff they look like
the little up grandpa but they're
talking about how many people they
murder and all that stuff and it's like
they're so cute yeah it's weird to see
people like that anymore mother of three
still could be home thank you so this is
Sean the jelly man
yeah the jelly man and this was Sean and
his fiancee was pregnant oh he's a lot
hotter
she is a lot hotter yeah that's a bummer
because being pregnant is not easy you
know that sucks that she's going through
all this while he has a really large
head it's interesting that the flight
attendants didn't stop him yes so first
of all there was a lady sitting with
them quick to me this is not safe
no the lady was like what the hell is
really she started grinding up so she
was like um can I move and so the flight
attendants moved her but then when these
people were like complaining about them
like like look at what they're doing
like this is not appropriate
the fighters didn't do any what are you
guys are [ __ ] sorry as [ __ ] dude it
was a ryanair flight maybe they're so
used to it because we're flying to ibiza
where everyone acts crazy that's true
that's crazy so what do you do like do
you separate them like probably yeah you
do that's a safety hazard it is it
you're not even supposed to be pushed in
a suit like that can't even have your
baby on your lap like that yeah baby got
to be sitting next to what they're
crying I wanna be held shut up according
to this report here that dude after this
entire video went viral she just
disappeared I would Beyonce - yeah they
can't find him oh shoot who's probably
got a Bush outfit on and he's in the
frickin London forest I wonder if like
he knows how crazy his fiancee is the
show actually killed him because it is
appreciate the fiance obviously knows
about this of course she does
I never got her when people drink before
they went on a flight oh my god it makes
you feel different it's not why people
drink I know people drink before they
get affects ticket falsely oh like relax
slight anxiety yeah too much do muscles
in yoga also does the same thing you
could stretch in the airport yeah we
always stretch at the airport if I
really wanted to relax if I just take a
benadryl or something I just knocked me
the [ __ ] out
yeah so the last night dick and I were
on we were red wine it was really
relaxing I was like oh and I hate to
drink it is that compared to a normal
flex not relaxing at all no other known
as I mean you know stressors like you
could hear like all the noise going on
people coughing near you this is like
constantly on your mind but then when I
had this glass of wine I'm like oh I
thought about everything I don't know I
feel so lucky because planes are so
relaxing for me especially the takeoff I
knocked out during that time and then
I'm air I'm like it's so nice you still
find it relaxing when there's a lot of
turbulence I guess not but it's also oh
my god and the [ __ ] master yeah fine
here I feel a lot so turbulence isn't as
scary
I came car ride always maybe knockout
man crazy
I can't believe beniker what I'm done
when we bought a boat you're to the
first moment not so like I can sleep but
I'm not comfortable like I can't I can't
get a good rest
okay I'll cause you're on a plane yeah
my back shaped um when the seat is
straight up I'm actually like this and
then so when I finally am able to you
only take off you can lean or chair back
now I'm finally like this yeah I have to
lean back in order to be straight up or
else the whole time I'm hunched over
like this and I just feel so crazy they
make the sea so dumb it's a bit more
fetus like how does this come true it's
a fit more safe to think even even the
way that they design where you sit like
there's there a lumbar and lumbar
support so I'm constantly putting like
blending up my jacket and I'm trying to
put it there like some pretty supportive
so uncomfortable damn I'm a simpleton
I think claims would be a lot easier to
for me if I just dropped like 70 pounds
maybe still missing a super spillage I'm
all old yeah the disk
for size-wise I think I don't understand
that because I'm just smaller so it's
just easier but if I had those I
probably hate traveling - yeah my paws
like in business class this is awesome
the space is way better it's probably a
normal seat to you yeah and I also don't
have the crazy body heat like oh yeah
since I'm already hot and now I can feel
the entire heat of the row so I'm just
like much like I'm just getting greasy
as a [ __ ] you start sweating
yeah you're right Chris Wow when
everyone says to get on the plane and
they get cold I never ever understand
that even when we're going to Europe I'm
going to go on the plane in shorts first
and then when I get off I'll put on the
polar [ __ ] that I brought that is
exactly I never get cold on a plane I do
before I get on a plane that's exactly
knows what's up hot as [ __ ] your feet
don't get cold though hello oh my god
that cold you go in so you might even
like it on Chicago the fields do or
Denver a blanket letter it was
international I pretend like I'm
relaxing I'm about to go to sleep but I
had not able to go to sleep yeah I leave
my I let my toes pick up just keep no
matter where you go exactly that you
could be warm after you get off and then
put the sweaters of [ __ ] after the fact
while you're on the plane is too annoyed
to remove clothes it just takes up more
space on my [ __ ] all faster sweaty
oh god study ballsacks okay guys I hope
you enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if you guys want to share a
story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]
you
[Music]